what's up guys podcast number I'm not
sure but it's Marty's birthday today all
right it's Marty's birthday today
congratulations
it was great this is my gunshot
oh yeah yeah
and you're expecting it so how do I do
this okay
Smarties like I see you I know but like
I was gonna be ready for a water I would
tell the story
I'm gonna get it in there
that's what she said
so how you feeling man
pretty good man
I'm gonna get this [__] episode
underway
a new [__] Mike arms going
check
two hour drive up in this [__]
you think it wasn't Saturday check
traffic check
good
two hour traffic for real yeah it was
about an hour and a half oh [__]
what's up guys
yeah
oh [__]
you're about to break your [__]
camera hey wait right here quit past the
camera Break My Lens I know I was like
yo
all right it's August it's Marty's
birthday my birthday's next week so
we're sitting here just uh shooting
confetti and Omar all right we're
shooting Mexicans again
this is not what's up rockers nobody
cares we're [__] self we're sorry all
right guys see you guys in a minute
let's put this on the plate
thanks to Mint mobile breaking up with
your big wireless provider has never
been easier for a limited time mint
Mobile's offering plans at just 15 a
month that's unlimited talk text and
data for just 15 a month take advantage
of this deal today and go to
mintmobile.com forward slash Yola
perfect
[Music]
foreign
whatever you want to call me this is my
co-host Marty O'Neill what's up guys
hello how are you guys it's dope as
usual podcast and we're gonna get
straight into it today is Marty's
birthday
hey guys
[Music]
today's Marty's birthday guys all right
Marty just left his Twilight year Zone
year I can't wait for my everybody in
the Twilight Zone Mark age 36. oh
everyone's always 36 in the Twilight
Zone 36 was a good one good year man
that's a strong year I don't know why it
sounds so like I finally feel like I'm
starting to become an adult almost yeah
like in a couple years like like what do
you think what do you feel that is an
adult
I'm just still the same exact dude I was
like [__] I was like 19. I got you
nothing I'm gonna care more about
finances and like uh taxes and [__] like
that I think
I'm gonna learn how to install gutters
on the house and [__] [__] like that no
thank you
Al born anything Al Borland can do I
probably don't want to do
he could fix fences and all
[__] it's a shame to have another guy
come over and fix this I'll do that in
your 40s do you want to hit this yeah no
you're good let me know when you're done
if you want water let me know or some
juice
that's why dude everybody I don't know
how to do this so let me get you some
coffee anything that's what I tell
everybody the handyman guy like I could
totally hang that picture
but if you're here
hey I like 12 pictures you have the
level you have the thing the little
Chuck thing you can do it and said have
you ever hung a picture without getting
three to five holes in the wall
the push trees house behind the Mac Dre
picture there was seven different times
where I missed
and hit the wall with the hammer mmm God
damn yeah because it was an old house
from the 20s the wall was plaster
like it cracked when you hit it in there
so when I hit it with a hammer math we
used to call it math
behind all my Pink Floyd posters in my
living room there's holes in my wall
because I took algebra and I was taking
algebra in college and I didn't get it
there were so many times I get so
frustrated like how does that not make
sense I watched the teacher do it and
I'm getting a different answer
and it would get so frustrating that one
day I just like I just punched the wall
and it went right through it to the wood
of the outside went oh
I can punch through that pretty easy
that's not good because when I'm really
frustrated I want to see the wall break
into pieces because I'm so pissed off
hate math I'm not even that mad all the
time just the math when things are
logical like math and it doesn't make
sense
where did I go wrong and I can't find it
oh I'm a mass shooter in my own house
this is like punching the wall just
doing terrible things dude so yeah
um your house is terrible and old 110
years old so it's okay I've only ever
booted through a wall maybe once one
good time was it a bills okay
surprisingly no oh okay I thought you're
gonna say kind of
Marty have a question yeah what's the
first birthday memory that you have oh
wow the first that's some 80s [__] it's
back on a picnic table probably like
it's probably like my third birthday
because I have a picture from it me and
my wearing overalls or Oshkosh yeah how
did I no I felt like young white
children have to wear Oshkosh do you see
the [__] picture I posted yesterday
on my story it was that and some OshKosh
overalls my cousin my cousin posted two
pictures that I haven't like seen before
on [__] Facebook and I put them on my
storage me in a [__] tree with some
over I did see that I did did you have
overalls in the video oh yeah
guessing and I was thinking you're the
kid Andy from Chucky
like yeah he probably wear overalls and
Little Shoot look heads
yeah I think that's the attire of a 80s
90s baby
my best birthday memory though was we
live in this apartment building my dad
went up on uh like the second floor and
was throwing water balloons down at all
of us we had like the baseball mitts and
[__] oh
with you I was pretty sick yeah
that sounds so cool
that stupid little [__] you remember oh
yeah I remember that I remember you
throwing water balloons at us wow from
the roof
insane
yeah he was involved in a couple little
good birthday memories and she had
little street hockey games and showed
back in the day street hockey only liked
to do because of uh Wayne's World
they did it so I was like oh I'm gonna
go play street hockey and we only had a
can
hit it with a can and a stick I didn't
really playing in hockey I remember the
jerseys in chair right car car
game one game on remember they're
playing against each other in the in the
street okay I don't know Wayne and no
waiting Garth
watch that movie again it's a great
movie oh right when Will Sasso episode
was over I pointed at Omar and I told
Wilson I was like hey this is the guy
that punked Garth in Wayne's World one
he goes really I don't know but kind of
looks like her second one
I'm so glad he knew exactly what the guy
looked like when I said it
[__] person I loved it that's all
right so what's your first birthday
memory not with your parents
okay all right my cousin from Detroit
brought me down a sick ass rental car
one time it was my 19th birthday yeah
that's probably my best birthday memory
of all time is the one we give you
laptop he gave me a PC yeah there you go
but more importantly he brought down
this [__] champagne jaguar and let me
and Jamal [__] cruise around
Lackawanna and [__] bump my music and
[__] in it solo for uh seems It's
probably about [__] 15 minutes and
[__] but it's still soon
the Jaguar champagne Jaguar I can see it
a 99
probably
yeah somewhere right in there
might as well have been a phantom as I'm
saying those were so sick at the time
dude they're sick now I love Jaguars
yeah
all right so you know wait question I
never asked you this
oh never mind you're just hanging out
with your hood ass homies you guys
aren't running around that's your
neighbor you don't just stay there we
just play basketball yeah you just stay
there I was thinking like what did you
guys do just like go to the park and do
that like no maybe yeah yeah but like in
Merced it's small we go across town to
go to a house party did you guys do
stuff like that exactly it's a whole
different kind of
I feel like East Coast is very different
how can you fit 400 people at a party
there's an apartment buildings and like
you can't
what in Merced like oh go to the field
go to the house with a feel behind it
it's easy The Orchards
these almond Fields there's got to be
more to it it was all Streetball that
was that yes that's what you guys were
doing so you basically grew up like paid
in full
you know Ace from painful I'll just be
balling baby
yo Marty's dad must oh man and the more
I see everything the more I know Marty I
know your dad and every met him he's
just like
relax all right you're like nine going
his Hat's a little sideways he just did
the Homer Simpson into the bush and [__]
why don't you bring your kid out more uh
yeah he doesn't really like this kind of
move the music right now he should be at
your [__] at your show he's not really
into this style of music Marty's over
here going like this and [__] still hard
but you know he was like ah
he doesn't like the guitar
it's kind of crazy to think about your
dad's a badass guitar player and you're
like no I don't have no interest in
anything of that it was like magnetic
opposites for me crazy because I grew
like I said I didn't listen to Raptors
16. my parents were old though it felt
so old to me everything about it felt so
old that is different I just liked all
the old stuff I grew up with all people
I think is why my grandma's all like ah
there we go
there we go guys there we go distracts
you distract you
yo that's why we don't put up stuff
remember when that fell we tried that
was cool we did try should we just leave
it yeah let's take it down
You Gotta Wear it around your neck now
I'm kidding but
yeah you gotta wear like a champ belt
yeah it fell it's not a horrible idea it
fell down it's okay
um we were gonna have April on today but
she got stage framing show that's all
she's just right you should just start
socking his ass right now what kind of
crazy shot would that be if it's just
gonna get a soft turns domestic attack
all right so I did almost die the other
day in a domestic incident with her I
was talking about I had a near-death
experience so it is the birthday this is
a birthday story then
yeah technically what happened on your
birthday story of recent hold on let me
smoke yeah real quick before you start
before you start
shout out to Raw once again for
sponsoring the show
because we now have yellow joints
[Music]
thank you guys for supporting the
sponsors we just had our best month ever
[__] is looking best month feeling great
uh and after this we're gonna open up
our gigant we might open up during the
show
we just got a shipment in from raw thank
you very much thank you for that and uh
let's light these up Marty
you have a lighter right there sure
you guys like these new mic arms new
arms who it is
oh you'll be sick if they made Mike arms
that look like Jack's arms from Mortal
Kombat
like a metal a hulk hulk hand hold up
yeah you see what I'm saying I'm not
even that into that stuff and I just
think it's cool
you see the toilet paper holders they're
like people's hand and they're holding
it they're pretty sick you just pull it
it's it's dope all right sorry back to
this what do you almost die talk about
toilet paper rolls
yeah whole cans and near-death
experience isn't it we're in the
backyard I'm doing some homeowner [__]
with the [__] pool I'm putting away a
[__] umbrella and [__] I'm inside
this umbrella because it's leaking and
I'm trying not to get the leak on the
concrete okay oh wait wait you told me
about the rusty leaves yeah so I'm
literally like trying to avoid getting
the concrete rust watered up to to avoid
that conversation about the this
concrete is not easy to take care of you
think it would be anyway I'm finagling
this big ass umbrella I'm inside the
shed I'm trying to close it it's getting
rust water everywhere she comes over
with the hose
sprays me in the [__] face
clean
got me in the jaw clean
so I scooped her up in a double leg and
took her over to the pool to throw her
in oh my God you did tell me sorry a
cavemander over my shoulder and now
she's been disabled recently so like
just spent a long time coming I haven't
thrown her in the pool yet I haven't
been body slamming her like I usually do
she's been getting the pass so she slips
out of line sprays me in the face
yo nobody don't clip this for Facebook
don't do it dude they're gonna they're
gonna go nuts I need Peta calling us for
some reason I took her up on the hot tub
and I just
hesitated too long
so I'm like am I gonna am I gonna like
launch her in the deep end am I gonna go
in with her am I gonna like you know
heave her into the pool I'm thinking
about all that and she starts [__]
bucking around
with their hips
but I'm just on the little ledge of the
hot tub in the water I wasn't thinking
about that at all like Common Sense
would tell one not to do that
so then I just go full trust fall banana
peel fall backwards into the hot tub
and I'm like six two on a good day so
that's I could probably stretch my head
to the back of the hot tub so
essentially you had a full bird person
in your hands you fell back with weight
could have crushed your head
that's kind of insane
I mean right there yeah but like the
[__] superhero I am
I kept April above the water and
sacrificed my own body
down into the hot tub and took out two
big ass chunks of my leg oh that's right
yo falling head that sounds bad honestly
it took 10 years to [__] happen oh
the moment I realized we were falling it
was in 10 000 frames per second I'm like
oh Emily's gonna see me crack my head
right now oh
bro please
she was a helpless bystander in this
Aquarium
oh
see Marty doesn't get scared often
and that sounds scary that was one of
those like this is how a 37 year old
white dude in Orange County dies yup if
it's not the shower it's the [__] one
time you tried to throw it away oh my
God that's honestly that's scary and how
many times did Mario scared me on here
and I'm glad to hear you're slightly
scared finally
I guess so yeah and I only say that
because oh [__] it turned on
oh [__]
sorry Marty has gunshotted me 60 times
on the show
you thing is right when he oh right when
he turned you already knew what was
happening huh
that [__] was still going oh you can
see me
that was if the camera would have been
off you would have fully Had Me Andy
told me you were gonna do it I know but
you didn't know what's happening now I
had it behind my legs look it it was
behind my leg tucked like this oh [__]
I've had it for a minute
I did get Omar you watched me and filmed
me and you still went ah
that's good
uh we're trying not to set the [__]
table on fire oh yeah I've already like
to be a a tornado of ashes and you know
when tornadoes going there's a fire it
throws it around I don't want that to
happen
do the thing do the smoke thing
now guys this is a makeshift episode if
anybody saw my story over the [__]
weekend you know I had one clean
birthday wish for the fans
you know that [__] got put on layaway
lame
I was with him all morning going you're
really not coming are you serious so I
got to get my stuff done first it'll be
next Wingo come on
and I'm like talking about the hash
house yeah Hash House and he goes into
like Fluffy's next week goes oh Mike you
cannot come to fluffy episode and you
don't show up to yours
we should just tell them it's Monday
show up and it's just his episode
he's not gonna leave he's not gonna
leave uh but no I I he next week it's
gonna happen next week finally a little
jerk but who cares it'll happen when it
happens
um this was a nice celebration episode
too Birthday Episode birthday
I'm trying to think what was going on
last year two years ago was the Marty
episode right now yes in the warehouse
yeah
wow that flew by quick yesterday I got a
uh in your memories
we had just like got three months it was
like a three month memory and it was a
the shavo episode which is our like
fourth episode ever
we're just nuts man to think about shout
out to Chavo send me some nice birthday
wishes shout out to you and everybody
the [__] 12 000 people on [__]
Instagram with a nice birthday wishes
yesterday thanks
I was I there's no way I can get through
all those messages and [__] but I tried
to Larry David it I'm not gonna say
thank you to everybody
thank you everybody thank you I really
appreciate that
no it's awesome that was really nice
um
all right is that is that all your
birthday is that is it the most
memorable birthday ones you have my dad
do water balloons at me even if it's bad
you don't have any birthdays we're like
a kid beats you up and then you started
a football team and then won the
championship
no kind of Disney stuff nothing happened
April April has them she's soccer champ
she definitely had those she's the only
athlete in the family I heard oh yeah in
the room in the room
I mean I stopped having birthdays she
took over the [__] birthday thing
once you have kids and [__] that's
[__] good luck
yeah I just don't I just don't I never
cared about my birthday as a kid
never cared if Rosie didn't Emily it
wasn't going all out what the [__] I
mean she she gave me a party once or I'm
pretty sure I remember it that was a
Green Bay Packer cake
and Jerry the guy from the story time
that beat that Sereno up in the in the
thing and his hands are all cut open and
I'm like yo I'm probably gonna chill
with you no more
um he was there I have pictures of him
with fake boobs under his jersey and
he's walking around like a girl and I
think that's why I will forever have his
him on my side I think he knows like no
that fool has pictures of me we're a
kiss bro because he's a gang banging out
his face looks like our walls he he went
hard with the tats bro
um
but yeah that was one my mom threw me
birthday party and then uh
I remember this birthday party my sixth
birthday I got my first CD and it was
Please Please Me by The Beatles Because
I heard I watched Ferris Bueller and
Ferris Bueller sings Twist and Shout
remember he sings in the parade I'm like
yo that kid's in high school
just captivated the city what song is
that I asked my grams like the Beatles
all right then that's who I like and I
started listening to them and then my
mom got me a Beatles CD someone stole
the tape we had the whole birthday party
on tape and someone stole it from our
house when they stole a bunch of stuff
one day
but um it's on video somewhere someone
someone that little skinny anorexic
child is me so remember with the emo
haircut that's all me it was a mohawk
and it wasn't put up so I look like a
little emo kid it's all shaved all the
way up Mohawk emo Hawk emo Tony Hawk we
should have had no Tony Hawk wear a wig
yo we got to be this man's manager come
on you got to start doing reviews as a
mohawk anyway here we go uh
my mom's best friend who passed away her
daughter's name is Ariel and me and her
didn't like I thought she was the most
annoying person ever she was just a kid
we didn't really get along but you know
when you I don't know if you know the or
if you had this experience of like
that's my mom's friend and her daughter
you guys are gonna get married when
you're older wouldn't that be cool if
art son and your daughter got me love
like shut the shut up I don't like her
she's dumb and I was like six
on my sixth birthday and she's the
biggest brat in the world like she would
just crying constantly I don't know
about now she's probably just an adult
you know she's amazed to me but uh I
remember we were hitting a stick I had
like a like a stick and we're hitting
the pinata and it was my turn and it's
on camera
and little me I hate my mom for it she's
making me wear velcro strap sandals with
two strap
oh
if your parents didn't buy you those and
make you do it you're a hiker or you
like look at children because I don't
trust those sandals if you're a girl
that wears them it's okay it's just
gross
dudes unless you're from another country
because that's just a tire two velcro
straps across top oh I hate it you know
which ones I'm talking about the ones
you can't even like
you can't do nothing in they're stupid
and anyway I had those and there's me
with a Goosebumps shirt purple
Goosebumps shirt I remember the day
I had my hair I had like a missing tooth
I was just getting my adults
and uh
I swing I'm I'm blindfolded I swing
I miss and Ariel starts walking in to
grab something I swing and I crack this
girl across the face with my stick bat
writing up
she's just
to go to the ground and I like
and then the candy Falls
because there was like it was hanging it
was like starting to open that's what
she came up to grab what fell and when I
went to swing I popped her in the face
and then it kind of swung and Candy fell
and everybody rushing nobody cared and I
chugged mad sodas
sick ass birthday at the park across at
the park next to gun runner in Merced
across the street 10 years later is
where me and John would hang out a lot
and smoke weed
Uncle John oh okay how crazy Jesus
Christ yep
that's it that's my that's my first
memory of a birthday party
a sixth birthday you know I really would
have thought I had more
or even birthday
no nothing
or remember do you remember years of
like I'm gonna turn how old tomorrow
whoa I was five and it was September 5th
and I remember we lived on stretch Road
right where Rosie's mom and dad lived
when I met him I was the road at the end
of Parsons on stretch Road where the
tire swing was I know a lot of them
fools just went for real okay that was
my house
and I used to crawl through the doggy
door a lot because anyone open the door
and I thought it was cooler
I was skinny anyway that house
and I were waking up and going September
5th
I will be six
tomorrow
are you kidding me six years old
and I thought what else I want to do
when I'm 19. and I was like what about
20. I just remember thinking all right
September 5th is the day before I get
ready for my birthday I'll remember that
when I'm older here we are and I don't
give a [__] I remember being scared I
feel like I don't know if it was Doug
funny or somebody but yeah dance or some
[__] and I'm like [__] at some point I'm
gonna have to go oh man yep
on the way to Camp soccer game today
yeah I remember having the same moment
he had when he but he's like nine but
just out of nowhere you started driving
with him and he'll start being like I
wonder what happens when you die he
starts questioning just everything just
like
it's right there under the surface like
he's sitting there wondering about it I
remember when I was seven and my
grandfather died thinking about that for
the first time getting [__] freaked
out
um damn this little 60 something I'm
seven
[__]
but then I'm like you know dude this is
something that scared everybody that's
ever lived when they thought about it
something that connects you to everybody
ever
so it makes you human what it was for me
was movies as a kid
who people die in movies or things
happen in movies I would start to think
like
whoa shit's real like an American Beauty
when he's like in one year I'll be dead
but this is the story leading up to my
death as you start the movie and that
[__] would get me to when he's at the
end he gets shot spoiler 25 year Grammy
Nom Oscar winner
sorry uh
after he's talking about how he's dying
and all the thoughts going through his
head and showing all like him and his
kid him doing this him doing it's pretty
wild every old person you see like yeah
one time that falls out of Carnival like
trying to get a girlfriend or hanging
out with the homie and that's the stuff
I think about like oh so I have the same
thoughts since I was like four years old
and it sucks yeah cause I was thinking
about the same stuff like you but just
constantly almost to a fault like
Malcolm in the Middle please watch him
out could you watch Malcolm yet we
watched an episode or two did you watch
I have paint on my ass that's the first
episode pink but yeah all over my ass
but yeah I think about shows like in
movies when gangsters die or something
like whoa that was just the next day
he'd be gone that's how I thought of
death I never thought of it as a family
members dying I didn't really have a lot
of family members pass away when I was a
kid at all first per family member I
ever had was my grandma I was 16. you
know so
that's creepy I'd have to
deal with it all it's it's weird trying
to explain the stuff to your kid or like
when they go through death the
experience and then you gotta try to
even when it's affecting you and [__]
not cool we just had a horrible tragedy
right next to our house oh the shooting
yes
saw that people it didn't really seem to
be in the news I didn't really see it
yeah Kirk's Corner this like restaurant
biker bar or by our house
so sad dude people getting shot a lot
and it's almost like I don't even hear
about it what the [__] it's so normal
yeah it's so terrible that just makes me
think I'm just so grateful to at 37 now
to have just to be like damn that like
I've just
gotten so much that I wanted out of life
that it's like I just feel grateful that
at this young of age I really
done like I'm I don't want to say I'm
good but I've it's like experienced so
much that I wanted it's like
I feel really satisfied with life at
this point
good you trying to fight then
let's throw some [__] for me and [__]
just start doing some [__] belittling
Marty right now
don't even worry on the drive home as
she's holding my hair and grabbing me
yeah I'm not sure where are you she
didn't go to the store right now she
went to go she went to Big Five and once
you get in that car she can put gloves
on and just start growing hard on you
got a screw it no she's 37 punches oh
okay it's your birthday
with a screw she's in rough shape she
hasn't got 30 seconds she's in rough
shape oh
hey what's up guys taking a moment to
talk about our brand new sponsor and
this is raw papers as you can see the
hat that I'm wearing is one of their
many inventions the first ad read I did
I said Josh is like Willy Wonka as in
Willy Wonka I mean you can make
everything possible you know the beer
helmets this is just like sickest joints
that you put in the helmet
I do smoke on it this is the kind of
Spencer's Gift [__] that I'm talking
about this is lyrical lemonade times raw
these are terpene infused flavored
lemonade cones it's straight up bud
pressed down as a wrap all sales are
through your local smoke shop your local
head shop but if you want to check out
all things raw Go to Raw authentic right
here popped on the screen rawthetic.com
and for all people interested in
carrying Raw on anything that they offer
hbi International is their headquarter
this is coming me and Marty were gonna I
don't know about just me and him Marty
and I are gonna smoke one of these bats
shout out to Raw just for making the
coolest stuff once again if you follow
Instagram and you saw this ad let them
know we sent you over there you smoke
damn near 10 papers today Raj is part of
every day anyway so this is perfect once
again guys thank you so much for
supporting the show and if you're gonna
smoke a paper make it a raw paper
oh man
um so yeah no birthday stuff that's
that's really it
I can't really remember much else I
remember my 20th birthday
I thought wow I am
20. I was at jeebus's house
and we got a sack of cocaine a lot
probably 10 grams we had like six homies
Jesus's mom was in Mexico she had the
water fountain the water cooler filtered
with the rocks in the bottom you know
I'm talking about the water thing you
get water out of and has rocks in the
black like yeah like the Rocks it's
supposed to filter the [__] out of it
and I remember like all right cool we
have Call of Duty Jesus's brothers uh in
his room we're all getting drunk uh
exciting glass door we smoke weed
outside Jesus has a bong all right and I
was when I was 20 and we were doing so
much car I remember my nose got raw the
inside her like
heard from here all the way like behind
my
eye how much you got to do before it
starts like it was just cutting sorry
crystal meth and Coke sack we got played
by a lot of a lot of coke is cut with uh
terrible things in Merced
I didn't really I don't think I this is
why we get in trouble damn it dude we're
so yeah it's okay though uh when we
oh and look and see and touch and see
like real
actual cocaine untouched since I moved
here and I stopped already so I never
actually got to do like
and I never will
sad I just missed out how did you how
would you really know if you weren't
testing it you're just like by doing it
and going oh I'm still awake why am I
still awake that was crunchy why is my
cocaine crunchy no crystal meth in there
man did you get me I'm just kidding on
the crunchy part but like I would
remember I told you I would gum 60 of
everything about an eight two grams I'm
coming
on purpose I love it so what
so it's it's bad for you though
but yeah if I if I had if I had this
much
that's how much I'm snoring
I rail it out and then the rest would go
like this
I go
wipe the whole thing up out of my whole
finger be covered like I'm baking and I
go like that
I'd brush my teeth basically and then
the bottom of my tongue where it meets
my roof my the bottom of my mouth
go right there and then
sit there
no cigarettes and just
that does it hit you the same as like
sniffing the car or just at all it's
just about numbing your mouth I mean I
oh I never just gummed anything so I
couldn't tell you if it didn't just get
you high
but I have ate that rock I told you one
time by accident with Joe and I got so
high and I got really paranoid and my
heart was racing but I was so numb from
like
I felt numb from like my collarbone up
not just my nag not just my throat like
I felt like this whole piece was like
swallowed I couldn't
couldn't tell you if I was swallowing
like if I was drinking the water would
probably just come right back on my
mouth like so Novocaine
I novocaine myself down to my throat
when I ate Joe's 20 sack of cocaine I
thought he's like gum that I went okay
cool because not that one all right I
don't remember that oh it was it ruined
the whole night it ruined the whole
night dude like we didn't have any more
money it was okay
and there's me not I didn't even put it
on and there's me just high as [__] off
Jose and he's like you [__] does
it hit totally different like an edible
oh [__]
what a question Marty I love it I love
it no it doesn't I just felt paranoid
I I never I feel like drugs don't hit me
then like like other people I didn't sit
there and go oh God I get all violent
like fools get on on when I want to go
do stuff like nah bro just want to just
chill
um am I talk more in power smoke that's
all I would ever want to do let's hang
out cooking's not good for anybody don't
do it don't do it it's all laced all of
its laced now you do drugs get a tester
from Amazon drug kit tester keep it with
you if you really want to do some drugs
test every sack you get please don't die
sell them on Amazon yeah I won't say but
one of our one of my friends very close
friends just she's in the hospital right
now from a coma from he was doing lines
and it turned out to be I have a
fentanyl in it I was in a coma right now
in L.A at the hospital Jesus young as
hell
sad
coming back a little bit moving in the
hands but like not awake
they induced him like it's crazy bro you
have to be so careful
well look with last episode we talked
about my guy yeah it turned out yeah
that's what
yeah anyway we'll just get on birthdays
[Music]
I don't know why
I think right I just got so disappointed
and offended you're just sitting here
puffing down no no no
you have to leave out there to smoke a
cig it's the last time you smoked a
cigarette
21 in Vegas
2021 when I was 21.
21 no no
when I was 21 in Vegas
um
that was it the guys are crazy I I if if
nobody else got offended I would have a
a air freshener smelled like cigarette
smoke
because I love this
I don't know what even when I was a kid
at my mom would be puffing saying
something like that
damn it's like when you little can you
stand next to the gas pipe and someone
leaves you go that's
that's yeah that's easy yeah yeah we
didn't have the luxuries we just like go
smell gas
I'm not I'm just kidding but that [__]
was bomb the smell of gas is Bomb all
you huffers out are you Charlie Kelly's
out there just went yeah yeah it is
but yeah um not good for you not good
for your brain and how do we get here I
don't know I don't remember either see
I love the smell of it oh cigarette
smoke air freshener
but I hate the smell of cigarette smoke
inside of casinos because it's stale
that's like old recycled yes the smell
of a cigarette when I'm walking down the
street and I go
still for a second ago dang that's just
most Bond and I keep walking because I'm
like oh
I don't want that in my body get away
with this in your lungs and now it's in
my lungs gross
came out of your lungs and I'll smell it
that means I smelled it into my lungs
enough to smell it still got some of
your lung on it now it's in my nose
that's what I think in bathrooms you go
on the [__] airport oh I've held my
mouth my breath in yeah I'm holding my
breath the whole time I've totally
pulled the shirt over my nose I've been
[__] getting pissed in this urinal
but the thing is to get all right that's
how many times I've done it to get my
shirt like that I have to like
Arch down I go down a little bit more
and I'm like that I have to pee all dumb
so if you ever see me in the bathroom
looking like this
it's not because I'm about to [__]
block her from Street Fighter it's
because you stink
this should separate bathrooms they do
for men and women every time I separate
like gross ass dudes with normals yeah
you're gonna [__] [__] bomb this
place and you're okay with that you go
on this [__] side you're gonna [__]
mom
yo I have such a fear of [__] in in
public restrooms because it's the worst
well you've heard my story was in
edibles
piss on the floor the other day I was at
the theater the AMC where did we go the
AMC and Northridge
I've read to tell you I walked to this
urinal and I stepped and I heard like
it's not like someone making macaroni or
something like
and I went that's my shoes all sticky to
the floor with water
and I looked at what that's
and then I continued to pee as I went oh
oh
and then I looked down and go don't you
drop anymore don't you drop two like
don't be pissing on the floor and adding
to this because I was just like get out
of here this place is gross I don't care
if I just pissed on the floor and get
out that's how I felt like
you know what I mean like sometimes when
the trash can is too full and you're
like
trash
oh it fell [__] I'm done and then you
just added to the mess that's how I felt
with pissing I'll be adding to the mess
all right yeah that's disgusting I think
of that every time not to mention the
bounce back
wow
didn't even want to go into it
but the same visit to the bathroom as I
pee I saw and went oh and I was like
this urinal was not it's developed like
a spoon and when water goes in it shoots
back out like a spoon and doing dishes
why no idea the man that invented spoons
made the urinal was like just you wait I
I make towels right so they invent the
black paper towels like I got you online
forever piss on yourself and wipe
yourself then do it again
you need a spoon too when you need some
hot air shooting aren't you going to
show that hot air is the best part about
the bathroom because at least I can go
it feel sanitary
hot air hitting me I've never one time
done that you've never used the hot air
no
you are missing out you could be six
five I think right now if you just use
some hot air I think you could Josh
Allen would have a run for his money
right now I think as the quarterback
starting quarterback of the Buffalo
Bills I mean the way we looked last week
you might have a [__] run for
his money right now really was it that
bad
last week was pretty bad they they
pulled out a win today we didn't realize
they played today we beat them insane
you didn't know the bills played today
how the [__] was that like noon or
something thank you it's a preseason
game still yeah you know about
everything there was a UFC at [__] 5
a.m today in Singapore all right you can
bring him out Josh Allen you can come
out so you can come out now
sorry Marty he's gonna beat you up 37
seconds
you know what's crazy you would say hey
what's up Sir how you doing Go sir you
are 12 years younger than or you know I
mean you were younger than me I forget
because you're so big
whenever I think that I think that's why
I feel like a kid's still because I'm
like I don't think of people what's up
19 year olds looking up
I was just shocking to consider like
yeah he is younger than me it's crazy to
think about yeah
all NFL players if you really think
about it are
In-Shape millionaires
like even the fat guys are in shape they
run four sixes and stuff bench 600
pounds squat do jump ropes and burpees
they're they're they're they're they're
they're they're in they're in shape
further it worked out every day on an
NFL level though like everybody would be
a little bit of that fat off I guarantee
those holes are gassed on yeah they're
as white as this table everyone's Jerome
Bettis
that's probably true yeah everyone's a
rhino
what's that fool's name come on nerd
for X-Men that has the helmet and just
the face showing Juggernaut nerd didn't
even get it
I love it because we're filming and he's
like I don't want to answer back because
you know we're filming so he's just like
uh
oh oh yeah I was gonna say oh oh my I
was gonna ask him a question because no
microphone
um so how much do you know about fluffy
going into this episode next I just seen
a couple specials he's just like he's
he's a really funny comedian so he's
like globally yes like when April's
sister knew about him I'm like oh he's
funny man Fluffy's like Peter like uh
Russell Peters yeah exactly well if he's
Russell Peters
not even just to Mexican people well if
he's just
kind of just fluffy
you're just like funny was he ever seen
like movies and TV or anything I just
made like a couple cameos I believe
that's crazy you don't see us just
somebody that's so famous just standing
just stand up he's just he's funny dude
it's not that he's just funny he's very
likable
yeah that's what it is he's very very
likely you just want to like I want to
hang out with you I want you to be my
cousin so we see each other at parties
and you laugh real funny and then you
make me laugh all right cool
and then he's a big ass fool so all the
big ass fools will be like all right all
right all right and he's Mexicans are
like I don't know it just works
we gotta we gotta put a date on you
doing stand up
um right now and I'm just gonna stand
you only see my belly button
I'm just gonna tell stories into my
groin
but they'll all be stretching backstory
so me and April will laugh so both of
our backs suck
she has a combination of both your guys
ailments I realize yeah perfect yeah
she's like like uh that fool from Heroes
and you want to absorb our powers but
like just the shitty Parts
uh Seiler is that his name Silo damn
Heroes look at that show sorry what are
we talking about birthdays yo I'm sorry
I tried
I tried to a idea mixing Happy Birthday
Marty and it didn't it just wouldn't
come through
we tried we got the app we got it with
Jay it wouldn't work we tried to sample
his voice oh [__] hey eyes there but
you'll help me because I couldn't get it
done what I did and then today I only
found 50 Cent and I was like I'll never
mind
because he was singing some of those
girls happy birthday Beth happy birthday
man you know you know game in the game
onto me
his birthday is about me there you go
this thing is a luxury it's so nice yeah
50 Cent
we're gonna have a push-up contest we go
on the show we're gonna go fist to Fist
and we're gonna do push-up saw like that
we're gonna put our legs up on the light
fixtures here and do the 50 Cent stuff I
know it's gonna break and we're both
gonna break something
somebody's got to win no when 50 Cent
comes here we're gonna have a diamond
push-up contest I'm gonna do push-ups
like that
I mean who was I just talking about your
diamond push-up contest
I don't know
were they talking to you
you don't even know how to use a
computer
I don't but what do you oh for the AI
Jay was doing it he was graphics
sure yeah this whole head this will had
his phone on his head with stuff he
wrote on his phone give me your phone
did you erase it already look at this
full Road
and he just had it on his forehead
people think I'm I'm kidding
people think I'm kidding one a computer
is one thing I just kind of
what was it like in 40 year old virgin
sometimes I just think it's been it's
too long and it's just it's just over
for me and I don't think it's ever gonna
happen that's how I feel about computers
like it's just silver for me and I just
I don't see it ever happening and that's
okay
good good movie speaking of which we
just invested a new [__]
computer oh can you talk about the
computer yeah like speaking of 40 year
old version it's all right look at this
caucus look at this
what's in here the lemon
the lamb and Papa
um shout out to [__] raw shout
out to Raw again once again go check out
the article on the website too if you
want to know more those usualpodcast.com
website looks sick
Sky I know built it also you get a new
computer you said
yes I am so [__] excited we got this
Adele yeah no it's like this like uh
yeah Dell no Adele the singer she has
her own computer what's that noise
oh it's Rosie's thing I see Rosie half
with a hat joint half rolled and her
going sorry
uh
you got Adele we got this laptop that
I've been using now way before the
podcast even started I think it was when
we did like that Rolls Royce HotBox
video dude my [__] was crashing and then
switch to the laptop but a laptop is not
meant to be edited in all those footage
that we do it's I'm surprised it should
have I didn't realize that's what you
were doing this whole time you've been
editing every Dope video off that and
the podcast yes I've been editing
without speakers really he's a truck
driver that only has I'm almost out of
this much of the window basically yeah
and Marty doesn't wear his contacts we
found out yeah that's the only thing I'm
when I'm home I'm blind so I've been at
it off this little screen of the window
right up on the working screen like this
all day so now I got the big beautiful
screen we got the Mac Studio coming I'm
gonna give away one of my uh Macs to
somebody that signs up for the online
course smart IMAX smart
yeah good so I feel really great it's
gonna save me hours across the board
I'll be saving years soon through this
[__] computer
so thank you guys that was necessary I
feel I'm so [__] excited
oh I think you have a little confetti on
your head I hope so you do right in the
middle boom
it's all right it's all right birthdays
oh real quick I don't know if he watches
but I remember I won't say your last
name I graduated high school you
sure you have a friend that's like
you know that story sounds fake as hell
a lot of people probably think that's
that's useful like hold on my stories
are
legitimate and there was other humans
there you know what I'm saying like
I had a friend in high school that would
just like
all right Michael Jackson did not come
over to use the bathroom but his sister
did like in Goonies like Garth junk
Michael Jackson did not show up to your
house yesterday yeah he did okay no he
didn't but his sister did that I have a
homie like that isn't it oh I can't say
his name Veronica Vaughn yeah that
Veronica let's call him uh
let's just say his name let's say his
last name his name was Joey
let's just say his name is Joe the first
real name yeah it was real nice
and he
yo man it's just funny all right no
guess that don't get upset
sorry I don't even I only thought of him
because he was at my 20th birthday when
we did cocaine the last thing I ever saw
okay
it was graduation
and he didn't show up for like the day
before school
and we knew he was like trying to like
be a boxer and do stuff and he was just
out of [__] he played football on me he
was not a starter okay not a very
athletic guy
that I thought
maybe now he's like a beast I'm not
trying to make fun of him just trying to
make it funny everywhere in high school
all right here we go uh I'm sorry not
make funny I'm just trying to tell a
funny story here we go
and this Fool's like yeah I'll be boxing
and stuff like oh hell yeah that's cool
man but he would say outlandish things
like did you really do that this weekend
so you've been training for how long
and you're already like
you're a champ okay
you've never come bruised once to school
I've never seen you with a black guy you
just started training and now you're
already beating people and contending
like oh that's crazy man that's crazy
you know we're 17.
tight tight we never heard of it never
seen in the newspaper
there's no boxing stuff happening I know
what you mean you're a dick you're
addiction
um
comes to graduation comes to graduation
and goes yeah man yeah I didn't show up
I was like what were you at fool come on
it's the last day of school unicorn
you're just one of those like it's it
you just come up to graduation
like yeah like I gotta fight tomorrow
like Oscar De La Hoya saw me fight now
he wants me to fight for him all right
what did you say
and I remember I look at my homie homie
brat I went
visually like telepathically went let's
a bit
it's just too much remember when Rogan
called Brian Callan on being a tough guy
he's like stop
that's not how you act I've been around
he's like hear me called him on it
that's how I felt this time like no
stop that it's like yeah as he's like
yeah I'll still I guess he saw me fight
he's like waiting for one of those like
are you gonna say something and that's
when I looked at my homies like this
can we do it
stop it
it's like yeah
he saw me fight he wants me to go for a
golden Golden Glove Oscar was Oscar the
Hoya's fighting Club Golden Boy Golden
Boy boxing or golden something about
Golden
and we're like I told him like Joe you
tell me I said he saw he fight and was
impressed I'm not doubting you but
you're telling me that Oscar that's why
you didn't come to the last day of
school you went to Los Angeles and came
back already
you're fat that's what I kept thinking
like you're fat
and he went with it
no no no no in my head I kept thinking
you're as fat as I am
I'll beat you there
and we haven't met we we
graduated on the football field in
college and there's a track there like
well I'll beat you right now let's go
foot race
I do cocaine every day and I'll beat you
in a foot race right now I'm full of
McDonald's and cocaine
and uh
yeah you saw him for Golden close boxing
and like yeah he wants me to go try out
after after graduation so that's why I'm
not going to go out to any parties and
stuff
I was like just say you didn't want to
go to any parties and nobody asked you
to go don't say Oscar De La Hoya is so
impressed that he needs you to and then
what happened nothing
then he showed up at our party and I was
like you're fatter than you were when I
was 18.
all right and it's the last time I ever
saw
damn 20 years old so my 20th birthday
my pro boxer friend got us a bunch of
cocaine
well that was it that's my party my
birthday party store yours is all
wholesome
I just play ball man yeah I thought I
had more birthday stories I'm really
trying to [__] I'm only thinking of
stuff that happened around my my 21st
birthday I was Ralph and Shireen in San
Francisco
I wanted to walk around San Francisco
and go to bars that's what I wanted to
do
that's it well speaking of which
again very sorry to hear about your
cousin you're just up in San Francisco
I'm sorry yeah
oh wow how Wild is that I said that then
yeah my cousin Melissa passed away is
really lame it's really lame
um
yesterday yeah it was really uh two days
ago
oh no Christopher Merced she was uh
probably your professor at the college
she's a only
actual professor in our family or
teacher or
yes
you got cancer out of nowhere randomly
right after Uncle John yeah
yeah then it was going good and then I
went up there when I was in San
Francisco that's why you remember for
Rosie's rays
I don't know what was I like talking to
her she was chilling it's just so weird
I haven't chill with her in so long
she's like 10 years older than me I've
been chilling with her in so long I
haven't seen my MRC my grandma dolores's
sister I haven't seen my aunt Mercy in a
while when I go to Merced it was just it
was just one of those houses where like
they would come over our house for
Christmas and my grandma and grandpa
died it kind of just went to my mom's
like yo you should come over here we're
doing Christmas with everybody and it
got almost to the point of like can't
just leave Madera in the middle of our
party to come down merci is Marcia
Marcia would you come over here like
well we're doing our Christmas
you know what I mean like that that
central place was gone my grandma that
was my grandma she kept she made
everybody come together and go to one
house and after I got and then we got
older and I moved to LA and when I would
come into my mom's and see my grandma my
mom her family her family her dad her
mom
and then it got to like I can't even get
to my hands right now like
I have to be over there I'm already an
hour late to my mom for Christmas I had
to go four places three places on
Christmas Day
I'm saying so it got to the point where
it's like damn I just talked to you guys
and that's rarely and that's it but when
I was growing up uh my cousin Melissa
was a I I told my mom I didn't know my
cousin Melissa was my cousin until I was
about seven or eight
okay because she's white
I thought the whole side of the film
here's what it's on the Mexican side no
it's in my white side but
I thought she was my aunt Pepper's
friend oh this is how I explained to my
mom like but she's like like blue she's
like white with blonde hair like looking
at Marcia
like yeah true
but
so when I was a kid I thought my aunt
pepper I knew it's my aunt
her homie Melissa
she's in the yearbook with her she's
like look we're in the same yearbook
that different last names it's like
there's no way we're related
you're not white you are my aunt that
does look kind of way actually so when I
was a kid I was just not like Oh My Aunt
Marcia which is my grandma's
sister I go to her house every whatever
I want my aunt would have is over every
two days we'd chill there and it was a
spot when I was a commander see it was
it was fun
but I just thought like why is Melissa
always have my aunt Mercia
's I swear to she was my cousin until I
was like in the second grade probably
I just thought she was some my aunt
Pepper's really good friend that was
always around
what a dumb I asked my grandma one day
and she goes that's my niece and go
stop what you're saying that is Amber
see his daughter
Thomas what that's at mercia's daughter
that's not just Pepper's friend
her last name is daily but that's
Marcia's name and go that's right you
guys have different I was a child I
forget that everyone has different last
names like that's your sister why don't
you have the name we got married
oh so it didn't make sense to me so my
cousin she uh when I went over there all
the time she was the older kid you know
she was like 16 I was like five and she
would let me chill in a room and she
never she was never a dick to me that's
why I remember she was never an [__]
and she taught me how to play Oregon
Trail and I would always starve the
families to death because I thought it
was funny
or get bit by stuff and then she's like
no you have to try to make it and then
she showed me like oh you have to get
this don't kill all the Buffalo I would
shoot every buff I don't care if I can't
carry them I'm gonna kill them all and
then it got to GTA like everyone's dead
but back in Oregon Trail
that's what I would do and then she
showed me like no when and I remember
the day I won I was like oh my God you
were right it was fun to win the game
and then she showed me how to play the
Timon and Pumbaa game where you eat bugs
remember that game it was on the
computer and I had to press the side to
side
Timon and Pumbaa and I'll play organ
Trail on the computer and then she
showed me wws and I would when you the
first year you were able to customize a
known character
I was playing that on her on her system
at home it would plug into the computer
I believe or no that was a system in my
in her living room but still like it was
just video games and she was a nerd
that's all I remember is my cousin's
nerd
just reads A Lot she's really good in
school which is great and then she
became a professor of English
so
yeah and she taught my uncle John when
my uncle John went back to college
they had already been married for 9 10
12 years and then he knows Melissa's
Peppers cousins our cousin
see each other every holiday my
grandma's still alive and uh oh no she
had passed away by that my bad but we
see each other every holiday anyway back
then and then we grew apart but
yeah John would have her as a professor
for a year and a half I think three
semesters
and he knew every inside thing about her
and he would just terrorize her
terrorize it because my uncle John would
always
be quiet not talk to people like I don't
want to I don't know them
and put on this front like he was not
super friendly
and then one day me and Rosie were like
with him at Raley's and like four
employees what's up John he's like hey
what's up man
the guy pointed at him like that like
you don't get friendly with that guy at
the grocery store unless you're friendly
to him
hey to the guy that's walking I mean he
worked there you don't care about the
customer unless you're like oh that
feels tight so this Fool's over here
making friends with everybody pretending
like he didn't make no friends with
nobody when I was in LA came back with
him went no
way then we were checking out the big
Mexican guy what's up John how you doing
and you can see he's like hey man
what kind of like
shut up don't pretend like we're not
friends because he always put on this
front like I don't know them I don't
talk to people
it's like you're friendly shut up you're
friendly and I wanted you to think that
or you just want a whole family everyone
like no I don't talk to him
but when it's just us just cracking us
up he was always like like a teenager
almost like no I don't like that stuff
like yes you do shut up
and then uh
and then I found his Facebook after he
passed away because I never had Facebook
and all it was was the most nice
friendly is positive I was with my
sister-in-law today what a great day
about my Aunt Loretta the one that he
used to make fun of when they got my
aunt got together you went I went back
through all his face what does John do
on Facebook I didn't know he had a
Facebook that's weird you have Facebook
like what see you guys the actual
thoughts oh man it was all friendly
being all sister had a visit with his
sister-in-law like are you a fan
you never told me
so yeah what was he like
10 15 years older than you uh
no his Twitter I made him make a Twitter
because he was so funny like can you
just like get Twitter and just say stuff
that you would say to me
so I'll show you if you have more video
clips with him or just that one no we
never recorded anything
that's how I was with my friends really
like yeah there's not a lot of [__]
did you finish your joy yeah oh my God
it's all right uh
we never recorded anything it was the
evidence
we're always doing drugs man
it's really what it was when you're
smoking weed and you're chilling like
you it's different what are you doing
cocaine all the time like we're always
doing glow Coke and drinking and I'm on
the rage he's not so there's not a lot
of times where you guys aren't in some
extra [__] Beyond weed when you're
hanging out any time that I sit down and
I'm breathing and I'm next to John and
he's breathing we do this one
that's it uh-huh
94 of our visit I'm like you want do you
want to go smoke weed in your garage and
we'd sit there we could just talk to the
living room too
we just sit there in a circle talking or
staring like right next to each other
smoking balls sweating in the garage
that's it
that's all we ever did how long did it
take before it escalated to those
what do you mean like have you known him
before it turned into like oh we never
smoked in the garage until I was an
adult
because then it's like yo we're gonna go
get high in the garage it doesn't matter
nobody says a word but before that we
were sneaking into the shed remember the
shed I used to cope by the candles a
candle and let it burn so we could see
the chop rails like [__] gold miners
I can do and Coke this day a lot
and then go back and play Madden no go
back and sit right next to my grandpa oh
God how odd wood would a wrap my
grandma's just trying to pretend that
we're not alone breathe up smell like
beer
and then
you play basketball and that was the
kid's hoop I'd shoot while he did around
then he'd shoot while I did a rail horse
H and we just say letters periodically
I'm not kidding did he put you onto it
or you put him on the road no you were
both of us doing that no I got him to do
it remember
I think I talked about I got him to do
it he was very anti-cocane hmm yeah it's
funny that we got into this talk right
now
it's crazy this is where I went
it's all girls ciao goes wait
did any of your friends do drugs
I mean like some peripheral friends but
none of my actual homeboys none of them
wow no
[Music]
it's just selling drugs yeah some of
them were
but no not really April's [__]
friends were
doing drugs
yeah but those are girls girls do more
drugs than guys I'm I don't know if
people know that
yeah but I have two friends that are
drug addicts like they do a lot of drugs
oh same
but
on the funnier side
on the funnier side of those stories of
those stories is uh
because I can't believe that people
don't realize like
99 I mean just for my experience girls
love drugs
guys love drugs too
girls with drugs is more like friendly
it's like yeah I'll share you want one
and it's like wow this is a friendly
environment in the bathroom and the
bathroom it's like dudes in the [__]
stall am I right all right yeah
oh yeah and then there's dudes in a
stall like who is that
different vibrator fight you looking
through the cracks of the stall to make
sure everything's good
coming out sweaty oh pissing on the
ground at AMC in Northridge
worst place you want to take a deep ass
breath in the [__] worst place you
want to take a deep breath
smell as hard as we can Jesus Christ
every time I smell like horrible [__] I
walk into a bathroom I only think of
Craig's dad spraying bathrooms
[Music]
I get pissed when I smell [__]
[Laughter]
I smell [__] I'll start pissing
hey what's up guys just taking a quick
break to talk about one of our sponsors
and this is draftking Sportsbook for all
the college football fans out there get
ready because DraftKings Sportsbook has
a deal for you this is an offer to start
the season strong for all your favorite
college teams let's get betting right
now for anybody signing up new customers
bet five dollars and get 200 in bets
instantly so you get two friends that's
400 in bonus bets instantly anything can
happen any team can be winning you can
win money right now you have five
dollars to spend and you like gambling
or you want to try it use our code Yola
and just try it out spend five dollars
get 200 bonus bets automatic if you're
gonna bet anywhere draftking Sportsbook
is the place for all new customers take
advantage of this and like I said if
you're a customer tell your friends to
sign up so remember 200 in bonus bets
off of a five dollar bet with DraftKings
once you sign up just use code Yola at
checkout so get in on the action today
get it on betting and remember if you're
gonna bet online DraftKings Sportsbook
is the place to be remember football
season's back college football is
starting get betting today
what's up guys one of our long time
sponsors hellofresh is back to offer you
a great deal for the fall hellofresh
offers to your door pre-portioned fresh
food ingredients and no going to the
grocery store no thinking of recipes
they offer everything they make
everything perfectly easy for you if
you're busy are you on the go come home
and you already have a meal prepped
ready to go all pre-proportioned and you
just cook it that's all it is there's no
thinking of what should I do I don't
know how to make masala yeah well they
do they have ingredients just follow the
steps it's fun affordable and that is
the reason why it's America's number one
meal kit don't call for takeout anymore
you have hellofresh at home it takes 15
minutes to cook everything and it's 25
percent cheaper than going to the
grocery store and getting it yourself so
hellofresh is bringing you the deal of
deals alright 50 off go to
hellofresh.com forward slash 50 Yola and
that is 50 off plus free shipping Rosie
and I are customers of hellofresh we are
busy it actually does help all you do is
pick what you want and oh yeah I forgot
I don't have to go to the store so once
again go to hellofresh.com forward slash
50 yellow and get 50 off plus free
shipping on your first meal kit there's
a reason why it's America's number one
meal kit guys get hello fresh and get
eating healthy today
I watched UFC the whole thing
no [__] first UFC I've watched in 10
years
the whole thing those girls at the
beginning from Brazil were crushing I
don't think I saw that those kicks were
devastating that Irish kid the white kid
was um dope yeah that was what's his
name
Gary or some [__] that was my first time
ever Gary no it's not Gary
that was brutal that was a vicious
Beatdown I wanted to see him finish that
[__] fight
I just know he didn't he kick that man
in the lake so many times he went to the
ground he was like sweep kicking it it
was bad oh that's right he started off
and kicked him so hard he fell yeah and
then let him out if you chop out a guy's
legal at a lead lag in the UFC it's
[__] over
I've never that's what always happened
in the UFC before yeah right
leg say lead leg a few times lead leg he
chopped that [__] down so he couldn't
even stand up and then it got to a point
that he was just [__] he laid he laid
on the ground started crawling him on
the ground he was like butt scooching
that was weird that was crazy
and then I saw uh Channel Mali whoop
that yeah yeah that was a good fight too
I might not I mean I'd get to stop it I
get what you're saying I might not have
stopped it I might have just because
he's the champ yeah maybe let it go a
couple more seconds because he was still
moving
but he wasn't really doing nothing he
still would have what like would have
won put it this way if this is a bar
fight you go like and you're home you go
I see how we do don't break it up yeah
oh yes you know what I'm saying like if
it was a fight in the bathroom because
the dude's doing drugs and they're not
as friendly as the girls
that's what happened two dudes are
fighting
Sean now you look great though I was in
I saw a video of him that made me love
him I I don't really watch UFC too often
but there's a video of him next morning
that just made me laugh and he comes out
it's like in the sun he just goes
and he's like looking around like as if
he's talking to his neighbors that just
I don't know why because that's exactly
what I would do without the phone
the things I do when I'm by myself make
me sometimes I look over my shoulder
like nobody else is here this is I'm
crazy I think because sometimes I'll
just say [__] for the comedy sake to
yourself yes yes thank you out loud in
my room sometimes half the should I say
is should I say is going clean over
April's head hey let alone
[Laughter]
jokes before the episode they were going
they were going
[Laughter]
uh what was it
um right when Marty move the mic arm we
got new mic arms they're not all bulky
and I was like oh my the last ones were
all P Diddy and he's like that's what I
said to April and I go they're all up in
the video yeah and now they're not you
want to get these little girls we're all
P Diddy right and then I I said he goes
that's exactly what I said April I go
see
yeah sometimes yo I I have ADD I cannot
stop I know this is too much I've been
like rolling these things I non-stop
just do it this is nice thank you Rosie
for the decorations too this is a little
streamer didn't really make it but
that's what it was
oh it's okay it's okay
oh more joints what's the plan for
tonight we're waiting for tonight
Lopez oh last birthday I was trying to
think
shoot they were in New York right
something happened
yeah no we were filming the we filmed
the music the music video last yeah
that's what it was
yeah
exactly
should just not feel like a year ago I
know it doesn't at all all right the
plans
are we got the van we got the Sprinter
we got a driver
we're going to my house and get huh
we get real high of a house and then
we're gonna go to dinner at Crossroads
it's a vegan spot I don't think you've
been to yet I'm gonna go to Crossroads
um I didn't know Marty was vegetarian
and didn't eat meat since he was a kid
until year two and a half that we hung
out really how uh we went to the
restaurant by your house and I'm like yo
Marty this sandwich looks good he goes
oh chicken I go all you want chicken's
like I don't eat meat what did you say
and you ordered a sandwich do is it just
me that day or because you you know him
though
you know when like
when when kids like start learning how
to grab food
and it kind of like gets it and rips it
and messes up the food you know when
kids do that
does Marty do that to his sandwiches
every time
he just inhales it okay because the
first time I saw you eat a sandwich you
took a bite of it it fell into you like
ripped it into six pieces and started
eating the peas I went what the [__]
and then the second time I saw you the
sandwich went oh I think it's just how
you eat [__] you ate the you took such a
big bite in the middle that it kind of
fell apart because it had more structure
to it yeah it's like eating a burrito in
the middle all right eating the two ends
that's kind of how I saw it did you do
that
oh my God okay I thought it was just
because we were here and you were
running back and forth and we were set
up cameras that day we were to plant
power like a year ago and I was like
eating a sandwich
that [__] didn't it looks like all right
I got one mode
I had I had like 20 brothers and sisters
in a past life that's why we ate so fast
this full eats like when puppies eat so
fast that their legs lift in videos and
then puppies start eating in the dishes
and their legs lift that's Marty
basically at any point
[Laughter]
oh they're having their own conversation
over there
it takes so much effort for me to not be
done with whatever we're eating by the
time April sits down [__] it's like I'm
like bro you got the self-control you
are like up there I'm not kidding you
know what I tried to do because that's
what my problem was as a kid and
everyone I ever met an adult would go
it's not going anywhere it's not that's
what they always say it's not going
what the what do you want me to do like
it's just me as a kid I guess and I
would eat hella fast and when I tried to
do one time
it was when WWF WWF Raw and The Rock was
still a bad guy
does that make sense that time era when
The Rock was still like not a good guy
and he wasn't super popular
and I was eating Kraft macaroni and
cheese the blue box blues and I was
eating it and I remember I grabbed
individual noodle on my fork and went
this is going to conserve the [__] out
of my macaroni and then I put one in my
mouth and I went and I flipped it
wow I have never eaten food so slow I
love it and then I did it one night and
that was it I did the whole Bowl
everything like three or four what are
we doing here I was starving I just I
just didn't want to eat my food so fast
and go that was it
you know what I'm saying like I would
smash my food so fast go well that's it
full damn [__] I was a little kid I
didn't realize like you're growing you
shouldn't just drink some soda yeah
you're like that's why you're starving
and then I would eat a lot of [__] like
that's why you're fat because your
body's like no don't store this [__]
this people don't eat nothing I feel
like that might have been it and maybe
maybe the constant Sunny Delight
I'm gonna move to my grandma's and there
was anything I wanted after that
I've never not just wolfed down
something I was eating I don't think
I've tried it's pretty awesome
making fun of it you're gonna build her
life
yeah my friends did
hey girl yeah no no no don't even worry
I got a good deal on this you want a
line
and the dudes over there [__] you
look at my [__] girl like I'm in the
bathroom full what's wrong with you
she was pressing dudes for money and
[__]
I've heard stories
yeah not just randomly
yo I wish that part was on camera uh
yeah I wish the expression that just
happened we did we did bug up we should
have had a round table today
we definitely should have had you guys
on camera that's insane that we didn't
but it's okay the fact that you just
said well not for not for nothing it
says it off
oh
God
I love it it's great
all right
okay
don't know where we were
have no clue
oh UFC
yeah April grew up with Sean O'Malley
and used to fight is that was that was
going on
she used to box on O'Malley that's why
she boxes dudes and presses them
oh Korean zombie retired today
oh [__] the fighter interesting last
fight today was that UFC the Singapore
one
okay that was his last fight today
I told Rosie on the drive here but
Korean zombie retired and I go I forgot
people age too I haven't seen that full
fight since I was like I mean it's
probably
I've only seen a fight once or twice if
it's the same guy I'm thinking about is
that you he's the MMA guy I saw the
headlight I go no he's an old Korean
zombie The Fighter
and then I saw the UFC clip like wow and
he was cut and he was like kind of
crying like leaving to the audience and
they were singing Cranberries Zombie or
is it the cranberry zombie yeah there
was the whole crowd was singing it and I
was like yo where's OG first time I ever
met OG that song was bumping loud in the
garage you know that that's ridiculous
you like the song Fool
um yeah so he watched some UFC
yeah we gotta uh we gotta start watching
those together somehow and doing some
[__] commentating and going live with
them now that you're getting back into
it yep
it's a monster we have to oh
this is not what was it oh man something
I said at the beginning of the show and
I was like yo I should have said that on
camera but also like
and I also said what if I just say this
is a bit because it is funny and this is
something I would say on stage is I
looked at all marks he was talking about
some [__] I was like I love
gentrification Omar and then I was like
y'all this is gonna get me in trouble
but it's still funny like if it was a
bit just be like yo I love
gentrification it was like what was it
your grandma has to move but there's a
coffee shop here or was it what did we
say it was like there's a coffee shop
what was it
used to be a crack house now there's a
coffee shop your grandma has to move
I'm sorry but your grandma has to leave
like she could was it she could sell
tamales in front of Whole Foods don't
worry that's [__] up but since I'm
Brown I could say that [__] on stage
people go oh okay okay it's funny but if
it wasn't like yo what Riot are you
trying to start you gotta run this past
fluffy oh I don't no no no no no no no
you might be saying like you shouldn't
say that and I go this is a different
type of thing I'm going for I'm not
going for the global marketability
they're not going to the private jet
with this [__] I'm not trying to get
a private jet off these jokes I'm trying
to get a couple fools going like that
and some people getting up and leaving
can't wait till that happened I'm gonna
have a Nerf gun on stage just for the
first person walks out just tag them you
want to leave
[__] you
is that a salt
no probably huh
I'm gonna paint it like a real gun but
you sure you want to leave yo Rocco
Rocco did his first little acting thing
his friends are in film school and they
did a piece and the premise was
Rock was like a corporate guy because
the premise is he's trying to get his
employees attention but the way he gets
his employees attention the board
meeting is waving a gun around
[Laughter]
so so he was trying to trade his
employee like this how you close the
deal
sign it are you sure you don't want us
like well I have a gun and you don't and
he's like I I it's it's a closer every
time and then it like comes back to it
and the kid walks in like puts the gun
down like it worked I told you and it's
just rock with slick hair like a like a
Suave business dude Rock has slick
carries in a suit yo it was funny dude
like it was actually hilarious it made
me laugh did that for a school project
he's not in school his friends are in
school Rocco's just gaming at home okay
and he's like I'll do it that's why he
didn't come to the ween concert oh dick
but worth it because what he did was
funny
but how ridiculous what a premise like
how do you get their attention hey
spin in the barrel hey could you imagine
day one of that day
yo that's good [__] dude uh was he still
moving down here
yeah he's moving down here soon actually
hit me up the other day about this
what's he want to do he's ready to go to
school passion is cool
oh [__] to like design clothes
yep and grab there and teach them
Graphics you can do the graphic part of
it for computers and whatnot and uh like
fabrics and [__] so you know so
basically the ins and outs of how to
graphic
how to put this together on computer
also how to cut and sew basically
good just a good knowledge bait like a
good starting thing happen again get
your degree so I can hire you for push
trees for the rest of your life please
please
great
start making designs man are you know
what I mean or something like that
I don't like what's the what's the new
Ratchet uh merch website by the way
ratchet world where are we going
is it ratchet Dot World
that's it ratchet Dot World
and then the other side is what's up the
world
right that says Johnny Dang collab
all right no it's ratchet Dot World he's
got a bunch of clothes I tried to put it
on today
I need to lose some weight I have this
area
because I put it on I was like this
so full of Fame and Alamar in the 90s
that's how I felt with it and I was
gonna like check like you know how high
those size
so checking Sakai yep [__] that's crazy
[__] Marty doesn't know about the
culture of that uh it's so funny that's
like a viral thing now let me see your
socks fool and then mine you're like
well I'm wearing I'm wearing Supra socks
the skate ones they are short you wanna
see my ankles tell me you want to see my
ankles first on my high tops this whole
[__]
they're checking socks
we're talking about of how Fool's gone
wild right before we started this
episode we were talking about fools go
wild
about how okay well why don't you pose
this to the fans let's go right now
Marty hits me up the other day and goes
yo I want to start a statement called
world star of the week Marty loved the
idea love the direction
I don't know if anybody would call
Worldstar relevant anymore he goes what
because Marty checks it every morning
that's his source of news so every day
Marty's like yo what political stance do
they got man gets robbed at gunpoint
Parolees okay sick and then it's like
[__] sexy Reds new album like damn
this this information is what Marty was
like craving at six a.m and he went Dan
that's crazy G herbo new songs
[__] about anything else but World Star
News say don't worry I check CNN after
like so you know about like
the war I've never been on an actual
news site in my life I have just a few
times for school
um
world star is so [__] boober [__] or
is it still your current source for all
things relevant in the world
these are this other [__] that you're
talking or whatever it is whatever the
other thing is
I feel like world star of the week is
kind of like saying
yo we should hit the mannequin challenge
today like it's not bad it was fun it
was cool people did it but I feel like
it's a little outdated because Worldstar
changed once that guy Q passed away yeah
they were more like um it's almost
unwashable it was almost like uh yeah it
was almost like yo I love the car show I
love your car it's really clean and the
next year Worldstar took over and was
like yo it looks like a NASCAR car
there's 62. it looks like our walls but
of ads yeah and Behind These ads yeah
you're trying to watch somebody fight
yeah I can't why I can't sit through a
30 second ad to watch a [__] ring
camera shootout sorry thank you a ring
camera shoot that's exactly the [__] I'm
craving on there dude and I haven't been
on Worldstar in a minute but I went on
last week and just like I gotta see I'm
like oh it's still working kind of like
is the e-bomb's world up that's how I
felt about it I mean there was about
time when I could make or break her
[__] life being honest for sure it
was like going on Johnny Carson as a
comedian like yo I got a world star
Worldstar Premiere what did they do
wrong they made a two available
they do available it started selling all
the ad space started selling it to
people that were it didn't wasn't
relevant in the field
um
that's really what happened I think but
I just don't think we're at warstar is
as relevant so you tell us in the
comments right now world star of the
week or what other apps do you I know
grind face is dope Graphics is cool
um
Fool's gone wild has stuff but it's more
for you know
fools
it's not just like everything more like
you know I don't I don't know I don't
know what to call it this film knows way
more than I do
is it for everybody I haven't do I get
deleted so much and it's not like I'm
gonna go follow everybody and remember
oh I was following Nike SB like I'm not
gonna remember every single person I get
to lead a lot I used to follow the
Fool's gone wild and they got huge which
is sick
what else
there's not much else just vlading world
star Vlad
there's not much else but you tell us
it's Worldstar we try to I try to
explain is world star is half as
relevant as it used to be
so would world star week at the moment
well-star week of the moment
and it doesn't have to be on World Star
but then again
yeah yeah what are we doing like yo I
saw some videos on the internet about
ratchet [__] of the week is that better
the just coincidence ratchets here
I like it that's all I do if I'm I mean
that's all I do come on man
[Music]
um
sorry hold on I got this I wanted to
show you real quick
because I saw it when I went on Facebook
I didn't I don't look at stuff all right
so I went on Facebook and I saw this
picture of my Uncle John
and he posted this picture
Is that real
look at his head
look how bad it is
that from surgery
oh cool comes over with gauze taped to
his face and I go stop what did you do
because
so I was drinking like all right John
what happened I thought that was like
cancer surgery [__] no it's funny I saw
the picture oh man I'll never forget
that let me look at it again though it's
pretty bad look at the direction of the
cut it's I'm gonna send you these
pictures to put up on the whole screen
it looks like a Halloween decorate like
a costume looks like you got bit by a
zombie a bit by a zombie's great bit by
a zombie with bad teeth is a great way
to put it you ready
all right man I was drinking Angel John
what did you do and he's like all right
I'm in the bathroom you guys stop it did
you fall off face first in the toilet
stop let me just explain all right sorry
I just really want to hear how you hurt
yourself and you go so I'm pissing he
goes
so I'm pissing
I'm in my bathroom pissing I just got
dizzy like oh okay
so I fall face first my Uncle John's
like six two I fall face first into the
bathroom window and instead of letting
go of my dick
I
pushed my face off of the window like
you know with like the pressure of your
own body instead of like
he's like just like I was pissed and he
said when he did that's when he got
caught and oh
he said at first it was just crunched
and then when it crunched it broke so
when he pushed his way it dug in and it
like took a chunk out
oh god well and then you showed me it
Henry took it off and then we were
smoking balls and John has a God Like
Ace a body different I got shot in the
head baby that's how he looked
but it was like this
don't worry you'll be all right my body
different
I didn't want to look on my deck
[Laughter]
that looks like it looks like you got
into it with a mountain lion maybe it
does the reason I brought it up just
Rose you know talking about the other
day and then I'm on Facebook and it said
three years ago John's rage made this
his Facebook profile oh [__]
dude of all things you made your profile
you [__] idiot
you can change before he passed away
without having forever it was Michael
John like the guy with the open face but
yeah that's him
damn he went out bad like that's that's
from him being drunk
oh and then I remember one time
I remember in Hawaii I just explained
that John drinking and crashing his face
in the bathroom because I found the
picture I just showed the picture I
found the picture
yeah and then um
yeah it was bad
I remember he knocked all his these
teeth out
and chipped up Jesus Christ you knocked
all his teeth he was in Hawaii
or he he hit them and chipped him I
believe he chipped all the front ones
same thing he was drinking in Hawaii on
base when he was in the Army and just
passed out face first he's like they let
go of my dick
that fool's got a [__] grip on life
with that thing I guess he did not he
just near my dick are like exactly tight
as it can be
and yeah that's what I remember April's
cousin that pass was like
on house arrest or some [__] he was on
house arrest he had an ankle monitor on
and he went to go sneak out of the house
snuck out of his window fell off the
roof landed broke his ankle and with the
ankle monitor that leg yes had to crawl
back to his porch and knock on the door
to have his parents live
that's incredible
oh could you [__] imagine that'd be
amazing
all right
what are we at what dirty
happy birthday thank you happy birthday
are those banana chips oh this is what a
healthy ass cake
look at this
strawberry cake and in this picture
sorry John I'm sorry John I'm sorry I'm
sorry but that cake matches that pretty
well that's not what I was doing sorry I
was uh I was getting something else
this is amazing thank you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
there you go happy birthday
we had Tyson on today
he said happy birthday
oh man uh that was awesome I I found
that today and then at the end he goes
Saturday it's not Thursday [__] up the
days of the week and at the end of the
club he goes I [__] up the days of the
week
happy birthday Rosie this is so sick for
the raver in you thank you um
coming out bust out my glow stick you're
glow stick fool starts doing PCP and
ecstasy
oh well he blew it out
that was very those candles like
what was it I asked for trick handles
did you yeah
yeah there were words he has the long
power of a God and just blew him out he
this thing actually doesn't blink it was
just a light and Marty blew it so hard
that now it's just quicker it's
flickering
I've never seen the cake this is like
the ice creams from back in the day with
the Strawberry Shortcake this is an ice
cream cake
pie they're soft serve cake inside of
this I mean soft serve ice cream inside
of this
it's pretty incredible Jesus Christ this
is [__] awesome
hey we had Dyson on all right they might
even get his copyright that'd be sick
happy [__] birthday happy birthday
it's not his birthday
oh all right so guys we have next week
we have fluffy on
right yes we have fluffy on if we film
with John we filmed with John you guys
let us know if you want the Hash House
episode I'm over this I'm over this
little jerk I told him this morning like
you know you're an ongoing joke on the
show you what do you mean we talk about
you every week what are you saying I
thought he was joking this morning when
he facetimed me with you I was like oh
cool we're good no
no every time I don't have a haircut
like you are so dumb
just wear a hat
beer to go then wear a scarf
Imagine John wearing a scarf on the show
I want him to wear a ski mask
that'd be tight too all right we have
one little baby joint left Marty
all right you know I was thinking today
we're in season three basically year two
right
one year to start February 8th 2021.
we're on year two
I am
I was thinking the other day
I don't I could see us doing this for a
very long time
and then I was thinking what do we do I
say it's year season 10. you know what I
mean say it's it's season 10. um
and we'll both be in our 40s by then
which is crazy
right it's crazy we'll be in our 40s by
then
what's like like you know when uh well
sasso's like what's the end of this like
who wants to do this for another 52
years dudes he made a plan for us
remember yeah like what's what's our
like
remember at the end of
The Sandlot and Benny Rodriguez hits the
Home Run and he goes
uh-huh to his homie up there it's like
wow
what a finisher but I mean their lives
go on to be great in this in that realm
yeah
what's our like yeah
and then what's next after this hmm like
what would this turn into
I don't know I was thinking about that
the other day after will Zazzle said
that 52 more years yeah yeah
whoa It's not that your season's over
you guys would be a hundred something
years old
that's interesting so I was that's what
I was thinking like what are we doing
year me you or in her 50s I mean we're
seeing we're seeing like the first
people do it with that first class like
they're kind of getting true true you
know it's like with my level of income I
can't see myself living the net modern
technology I can't see myself living in
more less than 200 years old is that
what he said Italian nights Mountain
technology my level of income I could
see myself 200 220.
but
that's crazy to think you're right Rogan
in them they're in their 50s yeah yeah
they're in their 50s how about we
realizing they're right up here [__]
how old do you think Eminem is 51. it's
[__] 50. yeah that blew my mind yeah
for sure he's 58. Doctor Who's 58 years
old yeah
she's gonna be 60. how old is Snoop Dogg
52 I think
and be a little bit older I don't know
yeah that's weird
how old can you look this up how old is
Robert Plant
you tell me he's in his 80s I'm gonna
smash this cake
into pieces in the plates and then we'll
all eat it but I'll smash something else
into this wall
75 okay that's okay that's okay that's
acceptable that's receptable three
quarters
oh my God he's 75 years old
yeah we'll see but keep supporting these
sponsors we're going to keep building
this team up and keep making this
more and more and bigger and bigger and
easier for us to put out and keep
building this [__] yeah guys we're here
just uh
trying to make it work and it's working
it's working awesome it's fun thank you
guys thanks for being here today was
chill we we we swear we were waiting on
John's episode to start yesterday and
then today and it didn't happen so we
both went we were going to film
yesterday on my birthday what what are
we doing then today was like a oh
so we're gonna go do a solo right now
all right let's run it we didn't realize
we're gonna do two solos in a week I
mean in a row we haven't done that in
like a year last week we're like never
filming on a Saturday again
[Laughter]
I thought you're right and then I
thought about like this feels right with
everybody here and chilling yeah we're
chilling we're chilling I gotta go to
Merced tomorrow immediately come back to
my back appointment do the chat
Tuesday's fluffy
they got film Wednesday I gotta film
Thursday got a busy week ahead of us
just drop story time we got another one
on Deck I watched it it's pretty intense
pretty intense
don't know when we'll put it out hmm
it's like that
okay
oh no
yeah it's one of our confrontation so
it's like we don't like putting out
those kind of Vibes to begin with it's
not like any video I've ever done for
sure although you did it very tactfully
and skillfully and I thought you were
supposed to be done as it is like good
job man yeah you didn't say too much
[__] and I'm the one that said
it I'm just going back like I'm in the
moment I don't know what I said I
remember when I said it was two hours I
got cut into an hour a lot of the video
was you like apologizing for the
situation yeah you're talking about how
horrible you feel that's how two of the
cuts of the nose I sent you were that
it's like yo I said that too much yeah
because I was sitting there just
repeating I took out a lot of them I
could I could tell
all right that is a [__] talked
about it very openly and I just feel
kind of like oh
and I filmed two story times in one day
that's the first time I think I've done
that
and uh on one hand it's like you have an
obligation to put out the stories that
mean something but then on the other
hand it's like we also don't like
stirring up [__] yeah
and for those involved I don't want them
at home going like damn I felt like [__]
now or yeah I mean
you know what I'm saying
I don't know but just don't be weird
don't be a creep don't be a dick and
everything will be fine
um don't be a creep don't be a dick
don't get shot don't get shot
yeah oh my water damn I haven't checked
any water this whole time
anything else you want to say Marty I
think we're gonna be rapid wasn't the
shortest Solo in a long time yeah we
have a lot it's Marty's birthday today
all right yo like I said I've been
watching a lot of Comedy enforcement
and I watched the Logan Paul one I
watched everyone's One Last Watched
Logan Paul cut the Brennan job episode
short yeah and I was just about to say
we have to go to a dinner
and that's exactly what he said to
Brendan Shaw but I felt so bad for him
but this is just me there's no guests
and we actually do have reservations we
actually have a reservation
which is insane that was grimy that was
terrible
um
all right all right and then Dylan
Dennis got a have you been following
that at all who's that Dylan Dennis is
uh fighter well he's a [__] Twitter
troll comedian really yeah and then
Logan are about the Box
but uh Logan
got engaged right before they announced
this fight okay
and Dylan's been going after his girl
pretty
aggressively online with memes and
pictures and stuff like that
but I don't know if the fight already
went on I'm kind of interested to see
because I'm pretty sure Logan Paul is
actually pretty [__] pissed off
wow I have no idea I don't pay attention
but I did just start I just watched the
UFC and went hey
it's the bus here we are nothing else
I'm getting more excited for I had no
idea how big the milk boys were
yeah those fools are huge
are you kidding you're saying that
because of their presence at the UFC oh
yeah
yeah I am also who's that guy wearing a
blazer with no shirt that Steve will do
it with Blazer no shirt you're you are
hard
that's what I thought like that was hard
Rosie because that guy with the Blazers
you're not sure but is that Steve will
do it that is awesome yeah you're
rocking Blazer no shirt you're you have
money now you can only do that if you're
Bond or a quarterback that just got
drafted that's it a Blazer and all
shirts Blazers no sure you're like yo
you don't give a [__] yeah I like that
and then like they're all they have Dana
White on the show I didn't realize how
big their podcast was it is I don't
watch shows it
or you're supposed to go on that right
no no something else oh that was a while
back that was a while back is Bradley
Martin with them he's one of the
co-hosts I don't know he hit me up he
got my number he's like yo come on we're
all talking but yeah for sure and that
was it I was like okay
I'm just text you keep texting yeah and
text you once I'm like what did it says
I'm not gonna display
let me know four times I just did it
once but yeah let me know about that
thing
so I don't know when that's happening so
yeah but yeah he's with them Bradley
Martin guy he's like a business table
buff guy
Arnold yeah he was like
had any ideas on the show and was like
really trying to I'm pretty sure oh what
do you say I think I'd be doing fine
that's what he said to him but I'm big
man he's like but he was like he met it
well then again like he's huge huge yeah
and if it's is it like grappling and
punching if it's a punch UFC fighters
are super huge and jacked and look like
bodybuilders not many yeah that's true
doesn't matter no no it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter I'm saying like if
this is like a
pin situation he might have him he's he
outweighs him by 110 pounds if you were
to try to pin Nate Diaz and they could
[__] choke the life out of him no I'm
not talking about a submission oh I'm
talking about like yo we can give me
opinion oh it's Razzle yeah I got you
it's a wrestling oh I got you yeah
I think if there's any type of striking
and our skill set involving martial arts
I think I think Riley Martin loses
that's just me saying it because God
Bradley Martin loses
oh if he beat him that'd be wide I'm
just lost to the bodybuilder God but
then again a big man yeah that's like
true that's like losing to Goro
from from Mortal Kombat with the four
arms in the ponytail so yeah yeah he's
huge he lost yeah but yeah I'm Johnny
Cage I can do the splits and [__]
dick punch man bro but if you lost
nobody to hold against you he's Goro
yeah is that a good comparison yeah all
right you should be Goro for Halloween
and attach two arms to your side tie
your hair back oh yeah you're gonna be
something else
I think we should be Nacho Libre and
like in the girl because I've been
trying to be uh the parents from Matilda
Mr Mr Mrs wormwood and I always flake on
getting my hair done
like when the hat gets fire is a fuse to
the Head I've been saying that since
we've been dating that's a tenure you
know what we should just do it
I just realized we need to go as The
Adams Family
we're we're perfect we got Eddie Munster
yeah daughter yeah yeah that'd be cool
that'd be a great [__] that'd be kind of
cool Herman Munster whatever his name is
and you had to dress up uh Ziggy like
like a thing
yeah
it looks like it we shaved all his
[__] fur he looks so oh wait is it
thing or it the hand no no the hair
thing the hairy the hairy thing from The
Adams Family yeah cousin it cousin it
nothing
did you just assume my gender
difference
oh man we can get into now people like
don't post that on Facebook oh man don't
post that I had real Joy posting our
Facebook clip on Facebook about Facebook
being lame people like that
oh man it's still going hard I forgot we
posted that on our own YouTube oh
oh it's still going the age restricted
our first clip yesterday which one the
uh DEA clip
I can see that
but you see that they sent us our they
they age restricted a video and then
they said you could be a YouTube Partner
now and I was like
this [__] wait last week we talked about
it we need 3 000 watch timeouts yeah
once we hit 3 000 watch time hours to
say actually we forgot it's four
thousand
3 000 activates like you can apply for
the low level [__] but you actually
still need the 4 000 to get ads in the
videos these we're getting there that
should take like a month
it took like a month to get there but
that was tricky I was like I kind of
broke my [__] heart when I realized
that it's kind of funny though
um thank you guys for supporting all
these channels we're about to hit 100K
on Facebook inside three months which is
what are we at right now [__] 85 90k
or some [__] really
oh
[Laughter]
remember at the end of little giants
when uh when uh uh what's his face oh
how am I forgetting his name
I feel so dumb Rick Moranis when Rick
moranis's brother is Ed O'Neill and Ed
O'Neill's like you never beat me he's
like you only beat me once suck it just
takes one I finally just got my my Ed
O'Neill on I just scared Marty yeah
you're dead oh he got the big shirt oh
[__] so yeah that's why the Roger man's
here I uh I I wore a shirt that's too
small and I was like you know what I was
gonna fit into it and then I saw that
picture I'm like yeah it's definitely a
little too small on me but it's okay
this is because this is my sitting shirt
I brought a standing shirt this is my
flexing shirt yeah that was the goblin
shirt everybody oh yeah yeah it's the
goblin shirt look at this look at Goblin
design let's go it's just hard shout out
to the boy Goblin hard
guys that was fun I got your ass
legitimately got you I didn't know you
had another one oh I had it behind my
leg for the past 15. since I drink water
it's gonna drink water last I don't know
how long ago it was but I had it behind
my leg since then yeah
Mentos the fresh maker
all right here we go oh I'm supposed to
blow smoke into these
but I didn't do it the whole time that
was stupid all right guys if you're
driving please be safe if it's your
birthday happy birthday and happy
Birthday Marty uh Marty made it on
Instagram go say happy birthday to him
uh we are chilling we're hanging out
we're about to go get dinner oh we gotta
wrap it up we have a dinner to go to
that was so mean bro comedy enforcement
I've been watching your videos Non-Stop
oh and the next time we're gonna see one
like yeah this guy wears this really
small shirt the downfall of Tom's like
damn I'm seeing this guys I like his his
he gets to it and I find out all the
drama I had no idea there was Dr there's
so much more there's so many more videos
I've watched
my back is injured so I just lay there
sometimes and go well I'm gonna get
someone to watch drama it's like
research now for the show it is look at
that
with the [__] shoot off another one
no look at that
oh one little piece got caught wow I
don't know that's insane you guys can
see we're talking about that's no reason
for me to say that on the show I'm very
sorry guys if you're driving please be
safe thank you so much for being here
this has been the dope as usual podcast
it is Marty's birthday we're about to go
hang out and get high as hell
um
thank you guys appreciate all the nice
messages and comments appreciate the
cake appreciate everything
fluffy next [__] week yeah
Marty C walked into the building today I
was like whoa it was a sea walk and he
was wearing lugs
it's pretty sick right on brown right up
Brandon brand he was wearing Dickies and
lugs
screw in his hand
oh Nautica dragon and he was wearing uh
what was it what's that oh that's not
good that's not good he was wearing
Coogi that's right he's wearing a
colorful coogee deal with that yo if you
were kuji you look like this exactly you
look just like this and everybody
thought that I don't care how expensive
it was I already went oh that Coogi [__]
Goofy
it was it was some fools look tight
though I will admit some fools kind of
look tight wearing Koji but not me guys
thank you so much for being here I
appreciate it from Marty and I this has
been the Doge usual podcast we we talked
about birthdays and my uncle passing out
I have no idea what we talked about
today I don't know but that image of his
head next to the cake is like incredible
it's not even baked either that's the
best part about it
all right Marty that was a good one I
like this appreciate you guys I totally
get it now yeah yeah oh
guys thank you so much for being here
this has been another episode of the
dopes user podcast next week is Fluffy
like Marty said and then we'll see we'll
see if our friend comes after that if
not it's okay add
I can't stop I can't stop dude we can't
stop guys thank you so much for being
here this is double juice podcast leave
a like a notification bell all that
stuff dope as usualpodcast.com go check
it out it has all of our write-ups has
everything meet the host that shit's
heart the meat the whole [__] is sick
um
you look real legitimate right now thank
you thanks for helping us
all right guys thank you so much for
being here uh we appreciate you until
next time have a dope ass day I didn't
think that was ever going to end I was
just gonna keep talking
[Music]
all right
perfect
[Music]